today is Jennifer Garner and Ben
Affleck's 11 year wedding anniversary
and they still haven't filed for divorce
one year after their split our top story
Jen and Ben it's complicated
Jen was all smiles out in LA yesterday
wet hair don't care
hardly any makeup and not a trace of
regret one year after she and Ben had
that tense talk on the beach and made
that bombshell announcement big breakup
news Ben Affleck and Jennifer Garner are
filing for divorce that came one day
after their 10 year anniversary and
here's where it gets complicated since
then neither has filed papers to make it
official and a source tells et they
still live on the same property in
Brentwood but with different living
quarters Ben who was snapped on set
recently fueled speculation about a
reconciliation last week when he
referred to Jen not as his ex my wife
was really really instrumental and
helpful and me doing a lot of that work
so what's keeping them together
well co-parenting for one Ben and Jen
have made it a priority just last month
the two vacation with their three kids
in London we're doing our best and our
kids are fabulous and for that they'll
be getting up and going to school soon
and and Ben is there and he'll be taking
them and where we will make it work Jen
told us she consulted her children
before accepting her role in miracles
from heaven
my daughter's so sweet she said mom it's
really your turn we'll be okay you
should do it and here's a question how
is Jen today after those reports that
Ben had an affair with their former
nanny Ben has strongly denied the claims
gentle vanity fair-- we had been
separated for months before I ever heard
about the nanny she had nothing to do
with our decision to divorce your Vanity
Fair article was so open and honest and
just wondering what kind of feedback
you've been getting on that article from
very loving thank you I think she's
doing really well I mean she's you know
in dealing with a lot of stress and pain
when your life shifts in any way
it's tricky enough but if it hasn't been
nearly as bad as you might imagine